تحدث قليلاً عن
عملية السلام والرئيس لقائك مع
الرئيس ترامب ، يجب أن تضعك
قليلاً على الفور
عندما قال إنه يعتقد
أن اقتباس حل الدولتين سيكون أفضل
وهذا ما أراد  لأرى وكنت
أتساءل عما إذا كنت مستعدًا للالتزام
مرة أخرى بإعادة التأكيد على التزامك
بحل الدولتين جيدًا ، كما تعلم ، لقد
اكتشفت أنه إذا كنت تستخدم التسميات ،
فلن تذهب بعيدًا لأن
الأشخاص المختلفين يعنون اختلافًا  الأشياء عندما
يقولون الدول ، ما أود أن أراه هو
أن الفلسطينيين سيكون لديهم كل
الصلاحيات لتغطية أنفسهم ولكن لا أحد
من القوى لتهديدنا وما
يعنيه ذلك هو أنه في المنطقة الصغيرة
بين نهر الأردن
والبحر الأبيض المتوسط  يبلغ عرض البحر حوالي 50
كيلومترًا حيث
يعيش الفلسطينيون والإسرائيليون في
تلك المنطقة بموجب أي اتفاقية سلام أو
بدون اتفاقية سلام ،
يجب أن تتمتع إسرائيل
بالقوة العسكرية المهيمنة التي تطغى على القوة الأمنية  إيه
لأنه بخلاف ذلك لن نكون قادرين على
ذلك ، لكن هذا دائمًا ما تمت مناقشته على الرغم من
الصواب ، أعني أننا نتحدث عن
الفلسطينيين جنبًا إلى جنب معنا أن تلك
الدولة لديها جيشها الخاص ولا يسيطر
على الأمن لم يقلوا
أنهم "  إعادة على استعداد للحصول على منزوعة السلاح
منزوعة السلاح ولكن من وفي الواقع
هذه هي وجهة نظري وقد كنت واضحًا جدًا
بشأن ذلك وقد كنت وما زلت تعلم أن
إسرائيل يجب
أن تتمتع بالأمن السائد وليس
الأمم المتحدة وليس كندا  لا
أعرف ما إذا كان بإمكان القوات الأسترالية الأسترالية
أن تتمتع القوات الإسرائيلية
بالسيطرة الأمنية وإلا فسيتم الاستيلاء على هذا المكان من
قبل الإرهابيين الإسلاميين إما
- داعش أو حماس أو إيران أو كل ما
سبق
، وهذا هو حالتي كيف يقول الناس
هل يتناسب ذلك مع دولة
لا أعرف أنك قررت أنك تعرفها
ويتلخص الأمر أساسًا في ما
نتحدث عنه ، هل الدولة الأخرى
المجاورة لإسرائيل هل هي كوستاريكا أم هي إيران
منزوعة السلاح بواسطتنا أم  هل لدينا
وعود فقط في الهواء ، أريد ذلك ،
أريد أن يحكم الفلسطينيون
أنفسهم ولكن لا أكون قادرين على ذلك ،
قال الرئيس ترامب قبل أيام إنه
لأنه اعترف بالقدس
عاصمة لإسرائيل ، نقلت
السفارة أكبر شريحة من على الطاولة  وأنا
أقتبس منه ، سيتعين على إسرائيل أن تفعل
شيئًا مفيدًا للطرف الآخر
عندما تعرف أنهم يعملون
عليه ، فلديه فريق عمل جيد ،
أيها الرئيس ترامب ، لقد قلت لنفسك أن
العلاقة لم تكن أبدًا أفضل مما كانت عليه في
عهد الرئيس ترامب.  إنه نوعًا ما
يجعل الوضع الذي تعرفه مناسبًا تمامًا
لإسرائيل ، كيف
حالك ستتمكن من قول لا له جيدًا ، أنا
بالتأكيد سأنظر إليه وألقي نظرة
عليه بعقل متحمس ومنفتح
لأنني أعرف ذلك  كانت صداقة
كبيرة أيضًا ، وأنت محق في أن
التحالف بين إسرائيل والولايات
المتحدة كان دائمًا قويًا
ولم يكن أقوى من أي وقت مضى تحت قيادته